[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHAD JENNINGS: Hey,
thanks for joining us.
So my name is Chad Jennings, I'm
a product manager for BigQuery.
And today we're going to spend
a little bit of our time talking
about geospatial
analysis and BigQuery,
and how our customer
Geotab has been
using that to supply
their customer-- i.e.,
municipalities-- with
interesting insights and data.
I don't know, how
many people here went
to the spotlight session for
BigQuery a little while ago?
OK, a few.
So you guys know a secret
that not everybody knows.
And so keep it to
yourself for a second
because I get to reveal it.
So we have one
feature here to launch
that I'm really, really excited
about, so let's go ahead
and get right to it.
All right.
So there are three of us.
So I'm joined today
by two colleagues
from Geotab, which is
a BigQuery customer,
and they're going to be walking
you through an application
that they've generated,
using some of the features
that we're launching here.
We're going to
present this session
like a play-- in three acts.
So I'll do the set up,
and then Bob and Daniel
will come on for the
main act, and then
I'll come up and do the wrap up.
So if you only have attention
for one act in our play,
it's the main act--
the one in the middle.
You can tune me out
for a little bit,
but pay real good
attention to the stuff
that Geotab talks about
because it is super cool.
All right, so here we go.
There are a few things
that we need to know--
to get the demo
that Geotab is going
to show, a little bit
of background knowledge.
I'm assuming that most people
have heard of what BigQuery is.
I'm not going to dwell on this.
BigQuery is Google Cloud
platform's enterprise data
warehouse.
It goes super fast
over super big data.
For more details, see the
other 67 talks on BigQuery.
[LAUGHTER]
I did want to dwell
on this one, though--
and so GCP has
over 100 products,
so there are over 100
little blue hexagons--
and I don't know
about you all, but I
can get a little bit
lost in amongst them.
So I wanted to put this
slide up to talk just a shade
about where BigQuery sits
relative to the other storage
and database products.
I'm not going to go
through all of them,
but you can see that way
over here on the left side
is the data warehouse.
It's kind of like
a relational data
warehouse that can go over
incredibly large volumes
of data--
real good for analytics
and dashboards.
I think this is going to be
useful to the folks watching
on the video as well to just
have this one as reference.
OK.
So now we'll get
to the-- so that's
a little bit of pre-work,
a little bit of homework.
Now we'll get to the cool thing.
So the thing that we're
talking about right now,
the thing we're introducing, the
thing we're really launching,
is solving this analyst's
problem, solving their use
case.
They want to be able to analyze
and visualize geospatial data
within BigQuery.
Right now it's possible,
but it's not super easy--
so we're going to change that.
So first, a little
bit of background.
So what's the difference between
a geometry and a geography?
So when my kids draw lines
on the map, they say, oh,
how do we get from
Seattle to LA?
They just draw a line
on the map, right?
They're doing Euclid--
although they don't know it--
the shortest distance between
two points is a straight line.
That is perfectly accurate,
except if the surface
that you're talking
about is actually
curved, such as
our planet, here.
So in this case, the
shortest distance
between Seattle and Stuttgart
is this great circle route.
However, Euclid was not wrong.
If you look at that
from space, you'd
get that straight line again.
So the point of this is that if
you want to express geometries
on the surface of the
Earth, obviously you've
got to take the curvature
of the Earth into account,
otherwise you get
the math wrong.
That's really the
whole point of this.
So can you properly do
GIS in BigQuery using SQL?
Any guesses as to what I'm--
OK, right.
Thank you.
I saw a couple
chuckles in the back.
So the answer is yes,
and that's the capability
that we're launching right now.
So we are bringing geospatial
data types and geospatial
functions into BigQuery
as first class citizens.
And that is--
I mean, I know there's
no fireworks going on,
but that is super cool.
Let's press in a little bit.
So this is a 200
level talk, so we're
going to get into some details.
I'm not going to
read all of this,
but what we're launching today
is native support for many
categories of ST_* functions.
So those of you who use
PostGIS will find this very,
very comfortable-- and I
put this slide up here both
as reference for later viewing
and as an indication that there
really is quite a wide
swath of functionality that
we're introducing here--
from predicates to parsers
and formatters, et cetera.
Here's a list-- oh, sorry.
Here's a list of the data
types that we're supporting,
so points, line
strings, polygons,
polygons with voids in
them, multipolygons.
And then a collection
is one or any number,
or any-- well, a collection
is one, any number,
or any combination of
all of these above.
The formats we're
supporting right now
are well-known text and GeoJSON.
We'll be adding support for
ingesting shape files natively
really soon.
Here's a list of
some of the functions
that we're launching right now.
A couple of our favorites--
we've got links to queries.
So if you've got access
to the slides later on,
you can just come
and click on this,
and it'll take you
to a BigQuery query
where you can play with the
joined based on STD within.
But for those of you who
use these kinds of functions
or have used these kinds
of functions in the past,
this should look pretty
familiar and feel
pretty familiar to you.
Anyway, we're super
stoked about that.
But that's really only
half of the problem, right?
When you write a
query and you print
out a geography in the
table viewer portion
of the BigQuery UI--
like for example,
there are census tracks
and there are zip codes that
have thousands of vertices.
And so if you just
print out that row,
you get 1,000 lat/long pairs
that makes for a very poor user
experience, right?
Tables is not how human
beings visualize or interact
with geospatial data--
and so we have a couple
different options
for folks to do viz on
geo data inside of GCP.
Number one is for
hardcore mappers.
You can go ahead and
use Earth Engine.
You can export geo
data from BigQuery,
import it into Earth
Engine, and then use
the JavaScript console--
which is that middle section
of tiny text right there--
to create whatever map
you want based on the data
that you just brought
in from BigQuery.
So for hardcore mappers like--
so first off, it's
a bit of a pest
to have to do the
export and import,
but for hardcore
mappers, they might
find that a perfectly
reasonable workflow.
And in our alpha testing,
it's borne out that way.
However, how many folks here,
they just go ahead and use SQL?
Quick show of hands?
All right.
So for you all, we
have this use case.
Hi, I'm an analyst.
I like BigQuery, I
just wrote a query that
has a geospatial data
type in the result.
Would you please let
me view that on a map?
And so to do that, we're
actually launching to Alpha
as well, BigQuery Geo Viz,
which is a lightweight mapping
tool that you can use to go
ahead and compose a query here
in the window--
and then you run that
query, and then it
calls BigQuery to run the query,
populates the results here.
You tell it which result--
which column you want to draw
and it drops it onto
the map, and then you
can do real time styling.
Now, this downloads
those results
all into the
browser's memory, so--
oh, sorry.
We don't need to watch
the gif go around again.
It downloads the results
into the browser's memory,
so it's not an infinite cache
of geo data that you can draw.
It's limited to about
2,000 points or polygons.
However, for the
case where you just
want to see the
result on a map, we
thought this was a much
better experience than,
well, honestly anything
else we could think of.
And I would like to point out
that the engineer, Mr. Don
McCurdy who did this, is sitting
right here in the front row,
so thank you very much, Don.
[APPLAUSE]
Alrighty.
Two more things you got to
know before we get to the demo.
Trust me, it's only two.
So BQ ML is one of the
really big launches
that we've had
here for BigQuery--
it was highlighted in
the keynote earlier--
but this fundamentally
is the ability
to create models, evaluate
models, and predict
on models all within SQL--
so we've invented
some new SQL verbs,
and all inside the BigQuery UI.
So gone are the days or
needing to export data to GCS,
ingest it in TensorFlow or
Cloud ML Engine or into Spark ML
or whatever.
You can do it all
inside at BigQuery.
So that simplifies life a lot.
We're going to use
that in just a second.
The other thing you
need-- so that's one
of the basic building blocks.
The other piece
of information you
need to have before
we get to the demo
is, who's consuming this,
and what's the problem?
So Smart Cities is a
data-driven initiative
to try to alleviate some of
the traffic or infrastructure
congestion problems that
are plaguing cities,
not just in the states,
but around the world.
And so growth-- and this is
a really significant thing.
This is not just us spending
more time in traffic
as we go to and from work.
Decreases in the ability of
folks to move around cities
is materially impacting
accessibility to jobs,
accessibility to opportunity.
It creates incredibly
high gradients
in housing prices, which makes
markets a little bit less
stable.
And it speaks also to
environmental sustainability
and the quality of life
that we have in our cities.
So it's a big problem.
And by applying data
and analytics to it,
we might be able to use our
infrastructure much more
efficiently.
Now, the cynical among us, or
at least the data cynical--
and I imagine there
are very few data
cynics in this particular
audience given the crew here,
but the data cynics might
ask, well, you know what?
Why don't we just build more?
Well, Seattle--
that's where I live--
can not handle a
400 lane highway.
There's just not enough room.
So we have to use
data and analytics
to do things like optimizing--
like real-time
adaptive spotlights
on streets,
ride-shares that data
and analytics heavy application.
My favorite one on this list,
ride-share and flying cars.
All right.
So all of these
techniques are heavily
reliant on data and
analytics, and so we have
to produce these technologies.
Google has to produce
these features
so that companies
like Geotab can
help smart cities decide how to
use their infrastructure more
wisely--
and so we've covered
a couple of things.
We've covered the launch, right?
So BQ ML, BQ GIS.
We covered the viz tools,
we covered the background
information-- and with that,
I will give up the stage
and let the main act come on on.
Bob?
BOB BRADLEY: Thanks, Chad.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, everyone.
So before we get
to the demo, I just
want to explain a little
bit about who Geotab is
and what we do.
So Geotab is a global
leader in a telematic space.
We have an open platform
from fleet management.
So for those of you that
don't know what telematics is,
it's connecting
commercial vehicles
and reporting where they are and
other information about them--
so it's kind of a
nice coincidence
that we're surrounded by all
these cool, colorful tires
here.
And so we have 1.2 million
vehicles-- or over 1.2 million
vehicles-- driving around
the world every single day,
and that produces 3 billion
rows of data each and every day
that we ingest into BigQuery.
And an interesting thing
that we do a Geotab is we
have a patented data
reduction algorithm,
a curved-based
logging algorithm,
that allows us to minimize
the amount of data.
So those three billion rows,
once they land in BigQuery,
we can explode those out by
interpolating into really,
really large-- usually tenfold--
data sets.
And I was going to come up
and explain a little bit
about the size of the
data we have in BigQuery,
but I just found out
from Chad before this
that the stats many of you
saw this morning, the largest
query ever written
in terms of rows,
was one of our employees--
so 28 trillion rows, which
was awesome.
So that's cool.
But we also believe we
have the richest data set
in the telematics business.
And why do I say that is
because we're much, much more
than just points on a map--
although, obviously, we have
no lack of points on a map.
This is one day of Geotab
data in North America,
but we collect a whole
host of other information
that's useful for
fleet management,
but also extremely useful
for smart city applications.
So we manufacture the
device and the software,
and on device, we
have an accelerometer.
The accelerometer measures
3-axis accelerometer movements
in forward and back so we can
detect harsh braking incidence
or hazardous
incidents that would
result from hard acceleration.
We can have
side-to-side movements
so we can tell if people
are swerving around objects
or if there's corners that
people are taking too fast,
that maybe they're
blind corners,
or you need add a sign.
And up/down allows us to
monitor road conditions
so we can do things like
identify potholes or bad road
conditions.
Another interesting
thing we do is
we actually reverse engineer
data from the vehicle itself,
and that includes a lot of
things that you'd expect--
fault codes, seat belt
usage, engine RPM--
but it includes some
really, really cool things
that you wouldn't think of,
like ambient air temperature
and outside pressure.
And we can use those
things to generate
hyperlocal roadside
weather and pressure maps--
and we also get windshield
wiper information.
And with 1.2 million
vehicles driving around,
we can actually predict if
it's snowing or raining just
by the activity
of the windshield
wipers in various areas.
And then we can combine
all of these things that
generate driver
behavior profiles
and tell if there's areas
in a city that are hazardous
or that need some attention
because there's accidents
there.
And if you want to learn
some more about what
we do at Geotab, we actually
just published a joint case
study with Google.
It's a really, really good read.
I'll leave it there for
the folks on YouTube--
and check it out, learn a
little bit more about Geotab.
Now, when Chad asked us to
talk about some of the stuff
we did with GIS, I wanted
to mention and make
sure we talked about this,
that Geotab has been doing
GIS in BigQuery for some time--
so we've been a longtime
BigQuery customer,
and as you can imagine,
most of our data
has a geospatial component.
So over the years, we've
been developing ways
to do geospatial
analysis in BigQuery.
And one of the coolest features
a BigQuery, in my opinion,
is the JavaScript
DDF functionality.
So we are able to use the
JavaScript functionality to bin
our data into
geospatial buckets,
like S2 cells or geohashes.
So what you're seeing
here on the right
is a map of temperature
changes, hyperlocal ones--
and as I've learned in my short
time here in San Francisco,
the weather changes when
you change streets or turn
corners-- and so this
is really, really cool.
And we can do boxes of
500 feet by 500 feet
and actually aggregate anonymize
our data and show it on a map.
And we can also do things like
create inline functions here
to do haversine distance.
So we've been doing
geospatial for some time.
But the GIS functions
accelerate this development
and really, really allow us to
build smart city applications
on top of our already
existing platform.
So that map you
saw before, where
we could bin it into
S2 cells or we could
look at using geohashes,
now what we can do
is we can aggregate and
anonymize and pull statistics
across arbitrary shapes.
So it could be a GeoJSON file,
it could be a shape file,
and we can perform all of those
cool ST_* functions that Chad
said right within BigQuery.
So now we can do distance
and intersection and contains
and all those cool things.
So that map we had before--
where we were looking at boxes
on the earth-- was really cool,
but we can also now just go
out and get some open data.
So I took an open data
set of neighborhoods
here in San Francisco, and
I can use an ST contains
and just find what
the temperature
is in every single one
of these neighborhoods.
And we can do this with
anything that we have
in our big data environment.
So now we can look at which
neighborhood has the most
accidents or the most
hazardous driving,
or we can look for
hotspots of idling
and make an
environmental impact.
Really, really cool
stuff that we can do.
And what makes it
even more powerful
for us is that every single
smart city out there--
or every aspiring smart city--
have their data in
shape files or GeoJSON,
and they also have
Geotab devices
in every single one
of those cities.
So I'm going to talk to you guys
about a real world use case--
and we've been starting
to develop an application
around this that builds upon
our open platform that involves
driving pattern and driving
behavior, and looking
at it in front of a
school in New York.
So I'm sure a lot
of you have driven
over these things in the past--
and so let's
imagine for a second
that you're dropping your
children off at school in New
York City and you noticed
that, in your opinion,
there are some people driving
in front of the school very,
very quickly, and so
you make a call into 311
and you voice your concern--
you're a concerned citizen.
And so what might
happen today is
someone would go out and install
pneumatic tubes across the road
and conduct a study, and they're
measuring the volume of traffic
that comes across those
tubes and the speed
that they're traveling.
And they collect the data for a
few weeks, they bring it back,
they analyze it, and
then they get back
to you, the concerned
citizen, with the results.
And what we think
is that now that we
have these geospatial functions,
we can spend a few minutes
and do a virtual study with a
virtual pneumatic tube using
the new functions in BQ GIS.
So before we get
to the demo, I'm
just going to do a couple of
little under the covers things
to showcase how we use some
of the geospatial functions.
So the first thing we wanted
to do for this demo was we
don't need to look at
1.2 million vehicles
to figure out what the
traffic looks like in front
of a school in New York.
So how can we filter that data?
In the past, maybe we
would've used the bounding box
and we would have tried to
use latitude/longitude--
but now we go to the
NYC OpenData portal
and we can pull down the
data set of school zones.
And we know, in this
case, we're looking
at the Neighborhood Charter
School in District 6
of New York City.
So let's filter by District
6 in New York City.
So you can see here we would
pull our GPS records in, which
would contain all of that
traffic information, speed,
cool stuff that we can get that
you can't get from a pneumatic
strip-- like types of
vehicles that are driving over
the strip, et cetera--
and we would use an ST contains.
And what I thought was
actually especially cool
about this was the NYC
OpenData portal had
the data sitting in a CSV, so
there was no transformation.
I just downloaded,
uploaded, and ran my query.
Pretty awesome.
AUDIENCE: That's cool.
BOB BRADLEY: Now the
second thing we need to do
is we need to understand which
vehicles are actually crossing
this fake pneumatic tube,
and the way we do that
is by leveraging the lag and
lead operators in BigQuery.
So you can imagine as you're
driving your vehicle along,
you're dropping GPS
points on the road.
And what we're doing is
we're taking those GPS points
that you can see
in red, and we're
connecting the lag point
with the current point
to make a line.
So we're making thousands
and thousands of lines
as they're dropping
their GPS points,
and what's important to
us is which of those lines
intersects with the fake tube
that we've drawn in the ground.
And so you can see
here, our subquery
is looking at traffic--
and so here's where
we're making those lines.
So we're using an
ST MakeLine function
and we're taking the lag
point and the current point
that we have sitting
in BigQuery and we're
making thousands,
if not millions,
of these tiny little lines.
And down below here, we're
using the Intersects function
to look at which of those
intersect with the line
that we drew on
the map so we can
get a true representative of
the vehicles that are actually
crossing in front
of this school.
So with that, I'll jump
out and do a quick demo.
So what you can see
here is an add-in
that we've made that lives
within our open portal.
So we have hundreds, if not
thousands, of these add-ins
now that are built
upon our portal.
We built some of
those ourselves,
and that's what we have here--
and I've left myself
a pin because there
is no way in front
of all of you I
was going to be able to find the
school that I wanted to go to.
So what we have here is the
Neighborhood Charter School
that we were talking about.
And if I zoom in, my complaint
as a citizen in New York
was that I feel
like 145th Street,
the traffic is just
moving too quickly.
So what I can do is
I can come over here
and I can create this
virtual pneumatic tube,
and I'm going to draw it
right across 145th Street--
whoops.
And once I have the tube drawn,
I can run the traffic study.
And what we're doing is
we're going out to BigQuery--
Chad, you got any advice here?
[LAUGHTER]
CHAD JENNINGS: That's
not supposed to happen.
BOB BRADLEY: That's not.
So what's happening now,
while Chad's logging in, is
we're going out to BigQuery
and we're looking for all those
vehicles that are crossing
that line-- thanks, Chad--
and we're pulling
back statistics.
So now, as an employee of
the city or the municipality,
I can get some information that
I can get back to the citizen.
So I can see, and I
know that in New York,
the speed limit in
front of a school
should be 15 miles an hour.
So on the surface, it
doesn't look too bad.
If I break it down
by hour of day,
it looks like people
are pretty well-behaved.
But if you look at these
average speed bans over here,
I can see 16% of the people
are going between 25 and 30,
another 3 and 1/2% are
going over 30 miles an hour.
So there are actually some
20% of the people that
are speeding through this area
quite substantially, so there
may be something to that.
I also get a breakdown of the
types of vehicles that we see,
the average speed,
and the trends--
and I also notice that Saturday
is a particularly bad day.
People are driving much,
much quicker on a Saturday.
Now, of course, kids
aren't in school that day,
which is great,
but still something
to be concerned about.
The other thing we did
is we used the District 6
to go out and pull in
information that we already
calculate at Geotab
for smart cities
around hazardous driving
areas and road impediments.
So we can see here,
the green represents
areas that are
hazardous, so that's
where we see a lot of harsh
braking events or swerving
or accidents happening
on aggregate across all
of our vehicles.
So while in front of the
school is not too bad,
just down the street at the
corner is pretty hazardous--
and this could cause
issues that back up traffic
or maybe that's a path that
a lot of these students
are walking to school.
And in blue, we measure
the road conditions--
so good news, in front of
the school is pretty good,
over here maybe could
use some attention.
So you can see
the kind of things
that we can do using
the GIS functions.
And what's awesome about this
as a developer is that it's just
a select statement.
There's no other work
that needs to be done--
and all of our data gets
to stay within BigQuery,
whereas in the
past, we might have
had to pull it out and then
compare it with shape files.
Everything right now happens
right inside BigQuery.
So that's it for my demo.
I'm going to pass
things over to Daniel,
who's going to show you a much,
much cooler demo combining
BQ GIS and BQ ML Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL LEWIS: Cool.
All right, so I'm
going to talk to you
about combining BQ ML with
the BigQuery GIS functions.
So for those of you who missed
the spotlight session earlier--
which seems like it
was most of you--
we demoed the tool
here, which I'm going
to get into more details about.
But essentially,
on the left here
is the current hazardous areas
for the city of Chicago--
and Bob mentioned the
accelerometer data
that we get--
and we can aggregate
those over time
to see where there are
particular problem areas, where
we're consistently
seeing relative
and scale to the proportion
of vehicles that are driving
through that area, and the
volume of traffic where there's
problems and patterns of
hazardous driving behavior.
And on the right is
actually a prediction
of where these
hazardous areas are
expected to be based on
predicted weather conditions.
And it's going to
be really cool.
I'm going to walk you
through how we actually
built this demo, and all of
it happened within BigQuery.
As Bob mentioned, we
never have to leave
using the new functions.
So as a data scientist, I love
playing with machine learning
models, obviously, but now that
I get to use these GIS tools as
well combined with
them, we can do
some pretty awesome and
powerful things that
were really difficult before.
So just stepping back a moment--
I mean, Bob already
mentioned this briefly,
but I just want to talk again
about how we actually calculate
these hazardous areas.
So we've got our devices
in all of these vehicles,
and we're constantly
monitoring the accelerometer.
And so the types of
harsh driving behavior
that we're looking
for are things
like harsh braking, rapid
acceleration, harsh cornering
relative to the speed of the
street where we wouldn't expect
that kind of thing
to be happening--
and we're also going to be
detecting accidents constantly
as well.
And we aggregate
these over time,
and when we look at the
accelerometer events
beyond a certain threshold for
multiple vehicles in this area,
we can start to classify
it as hazardous.
And we're constantly calculating
these areas every single day,
globally, across
the entire planet
and storing them
in BigQuery daily.
And so if you're
the city of Chicago,
obviously you don't care
about all of this global data,
you're just going
want to filter out
the subset of areas that are
relevant to you in the city.
And using these
cool GIS tools, they
can just upload a
shape file to us,
and then we can run a
simple select statement
and pull out all of our data
within that red bounding box
area for the city of Chicago--
which is super cool
and a lot easier
than what I had to do before.
Before, when we were still
doing this kind of stuff,
I would have had to do things
like cache a table that
had reverse geocoded
S2 cells or geohashes,
look for within certain
bounds, that kind of thing.
But now it's a one liner,
which is fantastic.
But what I think is even
cooler than aggregating
this information
over time is what
we can do in terms of
predicting the future.
So I mean, cities are obviously
really interested in what's
happening right now in
terms of hazardous areas,
and they're going
to want to know
the severity of those things
and how to prioritize roadwork
and maybe improve
signage, add things
like speed bumps and things
like that in the road.
But what's more
important is actually
being proactive and
addressing safety concerns
before they actually
start to hurt people,
especially in front of
things like schools.
And so I thought
a really cool use
case would be use some of the
public data that's already
available in BigQuery to
build a model around weather
and see how, if it's going to
be a particularly snowy day
or if it's going to
be a really rainy day,
we're losing visibility, how
is that going to impact traffic
around the city.
And the city can
maybe say, OK, we're
going to have a particularly
harsh winter with a lot
more traffic volume than we're
used to, what's going to happen
and what areas do
I need to address
before that becomes a problem.
So stepping back a
little bit, first I
need to actually
do a sanity check
to see if that's
something that's
even going to be possible.
So I took the last two years
of our hazardous driving
area for the city
of Chicago, started
to parse it out by weather
conditions, and looked--
was there any measurable
impact in our data from weather
on the relative severity
of hazardous driving
across the city.
And so I used a variety
of the GIS functions,
but essentially here, the ST
Snap to Grid functionality
to bin things across the
city and then calculate
the average severity score
and correlate it with weather
and produce some
of these cool maps
that you see here on the screen.
And so you're going to notice
they're a little bit jiggled
around there, so after doing
the aggregation with the ST Snap
to Grid functionality, I
just shifted them around
by the average latitude
and longitude for each
of those sections where
we're historically observing
hazardous driving
areas so that we
can tell the city
specifically where
the problem is on the road so
they can go and address that.
I mean, after
producing these maps,
my first thought was,
cool, this is awesome.
I can immediately see a big
difference between the winter
and the summer in these
particular days here.
So there's probably something
that I can do with a model
that I'm going to be building
in BigQuery to start to predict
these things before
they happen and see
what kind of the relationships
are, mathematically,
between weather and the
hazardous driving areas.
I mean, one of the cool things
that was non-obvious to me that
jumped out from this was on
the left, you see, obviously,
there's a lot more hazardous
driving and hazardous areas
in the winter than the summer--
but the highways actually are
proportionally less dangerous
than the neighborhoods
of the city, which
was a little bit
counter-intuitive to me.
So you're possibly more likely
to get into an accident going
to or from the
highway than actually
driving on the highway--
just because of the amount
of harsh driving relative
to the volume of traffic
that's going through that area.
So great, this seems
viable-- and historical data
is really interesting,
but how can we
actually use that to start
to make some predictions
about the future?
So we're going to dive in
a little bit under the hood
into how we actually made
the spotlight session happen.
So yeah, it's really easy to
pull in all of these things.
We can aggregate
with some simple ST
functions the hazardous
areas for the city
over the past few weeks
or the past few months
or whatever particular
historical period they
might be interested in, maybe
filter that by severity score
and give them an idea
of where they might want
to prioritize their roadwork.
And for a city,
this is super cool,
but I mean, if I'm
a city planner,
I want to address things, again,
proactively before they happen.
So what about tomorrow?
What about tomorrow
if it's snowing?
if it's snowing
and there's low visibility?
There's all sorts of conditions
that could happen tomorrow,
and maybe you could
go back and find
an exact historical
correlate for what
had happened with that, but
that doesn't take into account
your projected traffic volume,
your speeds on these streets
change over time, the weather
patterns change over time.
A lot of things are changing.
And so if you don't
understand the relationships
between those, I can't just
look at historical data.
I need to be able to
predict the future.
And so that's what we're
going to do using just BQ ML,
and we never have
to leave BigQuery
to do any of this, which
is the coolest part.
And so we can join
the data that we have,
our historical driving data,
with all of the public data
I mentioned that BigQuery
already has available
for daily weather.
They have this going back
decades for thousands
of weather stations
across North America,
and there's several of them that
happen to be around Chicago.
So I can interpolate
between all of those
and get, roughly,
for that day things
like the average temperature
broken down by that grid
that we did with ST Snap
to Grid functionality.
I can get the max temperature,
the min temperature,
the visibility for that day, the
total amount of precipitation,
whether it was
foggy, whether there
was funnel cloud
formation for tornadoes,
all of this cool things.
And then I can use
all these new BQ ML
tools which have been
announced several times
today to start to
train on this data.
And so in just a few lines
of code that you see here,
I'm able to train a model
that's going to be doing
all of this prediction for me.
So a few lines of code, really
simple, really powerful.
So in reality, it
actually created over
300 features for
this model, which
are various, transformed
versions of weather
inputs, combinations-- things
like temperature scaled
by visibility and
functional transformations
and things like that.
Unfortunately, that
wouldn't fit on the slide,
and Chad wouldn't
let me do it anyway,
so this is the simplified
version of that.
So if you just sort of
use your imagination
and the temperature,
visibility, snow, rain, and fog
here are actually reflective
of much more complex features.
But there's a whole lot of
things going on here that you
see on the slide, and there's
actually even more going on
behind the scenes,
which I'm also
going to talk about,
and which I think
is the really key part of
what makes BQ ML so powerful--
and what was going to really
make it powerful for analysts
as well who maybe don't have as
much data science background.
And so on the first
line, we're just
telling BigQuery to
create a new model--
simple enough.
And then we can provide
some options for BigQuery
and how it's going to
actually fit this model
and what kind of hyperparameters
you want us to use to do that.
But the only actual
required things
here are the model type and the
labels that I want to predict.
We can specify a whole
lot of other things
too, though, such as the minimum
relative progress, the learning
rate that I want it to use, if
I want it to do regularization,
what type of regularization,
the maximum number of training
iterations, the learning rate
strategy-- all of these things
I can tell BigQuery to
do, but I don't have to
because BigQuery is going
to handle all of that for me
and do this kind of
hyperparameter optimization
for me.
BigQuery's automatically
going to create
a train/test split of my data.
I can manually specify
that if I want to,
but again, I don't have to.
It's going to do the
train/test split for me.
It's going to set an
initial learning rate,
and it's going adjust it
during gradient descent
algorithmically.
I don't have to worry
about that either.
One of the coolest
things, especially when
you have over 300 features,
is that it's going to center
and normalize all of my features
to zero mean and unit standard
deviation without me having
to do any of that-- saves me
a heck of a lot of typing.
It's also going to
automatically one hot encode all
of my categorical variables.
I don't have to do that either.
And I think there's going to be
some additional functionality
soon that you can
automatically bucketize things
as well, which is fantastic.
And because it's automatically
creating this train/test split
for me, it's actually keeping
track of the loss by iteration,
so I can immediately go, as soon
as this model has been trained,
and quickly check for
overfitting, which again,
is fantastic-- and
I don't have to code
any of that behind the scenes.
I can do this with just
a few lines of code,
which is fantastic.
And just to
reiterate, all of this
is happening inside BigQuery.
I still haven't even
left the same browser tab
that I opened to begin
with, which is fantastic.
So this particular
model that I'm
going to actually show you the
demo for, I trained on about
600,000 training examples--
and the query for
training the model only
took about 15 minutes.
And if you remember,
I mentioned,
I've got over 300
features, so that's
over 180 million
data points used
for training that BigQuery's
able to parse through and fit
a model to in under 15
minutes, which is fantastic,
using nothing but SQL code.
So OK, you've-- yup, I'm going
to take a breath for a moment.
There's a lot of things
happening in that slide,
but OK.
You're the analyst.
You've set up this model, you've
gone, you've got your coffee,
you come and sit down
and wow, OK, the model's
already trained.
Fantastic.
Let's start making
predictions-- but not quite.
Is it actually any good?
Luckily, this
functionality is already
built into BigQuery for us.
So again, super simple.
Just a few lines of code
that you can see here,
in the rather self-explanatory
on the slide--
but I still haven't
left the same tab.
I can do all of my
evaluation off of tables
that BigQuery's already created
when I trained this model.
We've already got what we need
for a basic overfitting check
because it did that
train/test split for me
and created that loss table.
But we can also easily use
this evaluate statement
to pull out some
summary statistics
like the mean squared
error of the model,
the r-squared scored,
the percentage
of explained variance.
And I can see if
we're on the mark
or if we need to maybe go
back to our data cleaning
step, our feature generation
or selection stage,
and train again.
Luckily for us, I've already
done all this dirty work
and we can just skip
right ahead to making
some cool predictions about
where the dangerous areas are
going to be.
So after the last
couple of slides,
this is probably going
to sound familiar,
but we can do all
of our predictions
with just a few lines
of code-- and I still
haven't left the same
open browser tab.
It's really, really cool.
So the syntax here is almost
identical to the Ml.Evaluate
statement that we
were running earlier.
We basically just
pass in the model
that we've already
created and trained
and hopefully, as a diligent
data scientist or analyst,
you've already gone through and
done the appropriate evaluation
to make sure that
your model's actually
predicting something
and explaining
an appropriate
amount of variance
that you can use
it for something.
And so I've done that.
And so what is this
actually going to look like,
and how could a city use
this to actually do something
actionable with this data?
And so I'm going to
jump into the demo
and show you what that
app actually looks like.
So this was from the
screenshot that I showed you
at the beginning
of this section.
On the left here,
just to reiterate,
was the current hazardous
driving areas in Chicago--
this is real data, by the way.
All of this.
So this is the current
hazardous driving areas
in the city of Chicago that
we measured and aggregated
over the last couple of weeks.
So you can see that
particular areas of the city,
specifically in the
south of Chicago,
are kind of dangerous to be
driving around right now.
And a city might want to
zoom in on these areas
and figure out exactly where
these problems are and address
them, but as I'm
trying to reiterate,
it's better to be
proactive than reactive
in addressing these
kinds of concerns.
And so let's say that
it's coming up to the fall
and it's going to be a
particularly cold, snowy day,
and let's drop the
temperature down a little bit.
So let's say it's going
to be, I don't know,
maybe 31 degrees on a
particular day-- and there's
a lot of snow, so
maybe I'll drop down
the visibility a little bit.
We'll say that it's
snowing, and let's say
it's the holiday season
and people are really
excited to get out
and do their shopping,
and more people are on
the road than usual.
I'd say maybe traffic volume is
20% higher than it usually is.
So let's run the
predictive analysis
and see what the
model thinks is going
to be the dangerous areas
in the city of Chicago
for that particularly snowy,
cold day with a lot of traffic.
Boom.
So the map looks
really different.
So some of the areas that
were hazardous before
are still hazardous, so great.
I mean, the city
definitely knows now
to prioritize those areas.
But what's really cool is that
areas in the top left here
and in the north of this
city which weren't dangerous
before are actually
predicted to get
quite hazardous on this day.
So if a city's just
basing their actions
for fixing road conditions
on historical data,
they're going to miss a
lot of these areas that
can become quite dangerous with
different weather conditions.
And so if we actually zoom
in on a particular area
here that I found before when
looking through the data,
one of these predicted
dangerous areas
is right next to a school.
So you're looking
at historical data,
the city's not going
to know that there's
this dangerous problem
right in front of a school.
And so with this cool
tool, we can actually
use our little Google
person and jump down here
and see what's happening.
So if we drop down
a little bit ahead
of where this hazardous area
is happening and look around,
we can see the school
there, which is cool--
and actually, if you
notice up in the distance,
there is a student cross-walk
up there, which is great.
That's good signage
for safe areas.
But if we look around
here, we actually
see that the bike racks
are way down here,
next to this alleyway.
So students are probably coming
in and out of this alleyway,
and if we step over
here a little bit,
we notice there's no
stop signs and no signage
on this alleyway either.
There's no speed
bumps or nothing.
So the hazardous area
is happening right
before this alleyway here.
And the nearest signage
is several hundred feet up
the road near this
crossing sign,
but it looks like
most of the students
are actually crossing
here-- so the city might
want to come out and maybe think
about putting some speed humps
here or some additional
signage, or maybe
some mirrors around
these corners
and addressing this problem that
wouldn't otherwise be obvious
based on their current
historical data.
So hopefully you found
that interesting.
I found it super cool to
play with these new tools
and build these models out-- and
never having to leave BigQuery,
and we're able to train
this model on this data.
The actual model
trains in 15 minutes,
but even going through
all of the feature
generation and the
ability to quickly iterate
through training and evaluating
within the BigQuery environment
enabled me to put
this model together
in a matter of weeks,
which is really
quick turnaround for
something this powerful.
So with that, I'm going to
turn it over back to Chad.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHAD JENNINGS: All right.
So that was exceptionally
cool, and I did
want to touch on the timing.
So we reached out-- we've been
working together for a while,
but we reached out to you
to talk about like, hey,
I think there's good material
for a demo for next year--
and that was really
only two months ago.
And so getting spun up
on the GIS features,
getting spun up on BQ
ML, crafting the thing,
and then producing
that awesome demo
that's not just a demo
that's going to be fun for--
the city planners in Chicago
are going to love that.
Anyway-- so I just wanted
to give it up for Geotab,
both the speakers here
and the folks back
at the home office
who worked on that,
you guys did a fantastic job.
Thank you.
Alrighty.
So this is the wrap up, right?
This is the third act of
our three act play, here--
and I just wanted to
review a little bit.
We're not going to go
through everything,
but we talked about
what the launches were,
we talked about how Geotab
is able to craft that,
not just into a cool
demo, but into a product
that they can then--
like these are new
product lines that Geotab
and other companies
that want to leverage
this can then generate for
smart city applications.
Or, what's also getting
me excited about this--
right?
The third act isn't
the end, right?
There's an encore, right?
There are ring studies
for retail, ride-sharing
applications, IOT, media
studying DMAs and MSAs.
Using these new features
inside of BigQuery
actually opens BigQuery
up to enormous new volumes
of work, which is what
we're all about, right?
We want to make our tool useful
to as many people as possible
in as many different
domains as possible.
So that actually brings me
to a final analogy here.
There is quite a lot
of geospatial data
that's already resident
in BigQuery, right?
Bob was talking that--
Geotab has been doing GIS work
in BigQuery for quite a while,
but there are lots of
columns in BigQuery tables
that have latitude or
longitude as the column header.
So the data, in some
respects, is already there.
Certainly the data is
in other data stores
that folks haven't
brought to BigQuery
because we didn't support
latitudes and longitudes.
And this is the analogy
with Street View.
So was it back about
2006, 2007, Google
went through the
world's streets and took
pictures of facades,
street pictures like this,
and just logged where
they were in the world.
We made the Street
View home database.
What we weren't able
to do at the time
that we collected that
data was, in detail,
look into those pictures
and extract information--
like where are the traffic
signs, what are the street
numbers, what are the
retail establishments that
are at that location.
We couldn't do that.
Since then, we've
developed the ML technology
to look into these images and
pull that information out--
and we've even productized
those as Cloud ML APIs.
And that's generated
an enormous opportunity
for us and for our
customers in that we can now
look into these data
sets and provide metadata
on these are the stores,
these are the establishments
that are at this location.
And so we've actually been able
to generate a lot more value
off of this trove of images
that we collected a decade ago.
And that's the
state that I think
we're in right now in terms of
geospatial data in BigQuery.
People have been
collecting geospatial data,
people even have been
storing it in BigQuery,
but they've lacked the tools
to really go in and dig out
cool stuff like what
Bob and Daniel showed.
So I'm very, very, very
excited about this,
and I think we're at an
inflection point for this type
of work in BigQuery.
[MUSIC PLAYING]